Hi! This video is focused on the /d/ sound.
/d/ is a voiced plosive consonant and that means that there is a lot of energy behind the sound.
The /d/ sound is produced by bringing the tip of your tongue to your gum ridge and releasing it like this /d/.
One of the most common challenges with this sound is a lack of muscularity,...
...so you lose the energy of the /d/ or a devoicing of the sound so that it sounds like a /t/ rather than a /d/.
So listen to the difference when I pronounce a few word pairs:...
Add, At.
Bad, Bat.
Planned, Plant.
Also, the /d/ is a voiced sound, so you need to make sure that you carry your voice through the articulation of the sound.
Okay, let's practice.
/t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /t/.
That's the voiceless.
/d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /d/.
That's the voiced.
And let's put them together.
/t/, /t/, /t/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /d/, /d/, /d/, /t/, /t/, /t/, /d/, /d/, /d/.
Alright, now we're gonna try a few sentences together, comparing /d/ and /t/.
I don't want to wade.
I don't want to wait.
She bought a card.
She bought a cart.
She made her bed.
She made her bet.
Try this out on EnglishCentral and good luck!